three weeks ago he was the head coach in
the Miami Dolphins now he's the head
coach of the New York Jets he is Adam
GaSe and he joins us now coach how are
ya
I'm great how you doing Mike hey I'm
doing great and it just occurred to me
as we were getting ready to do this I
mean three weeks ago you're getting
ready to face the bills in week 17 as
head coach of the Dolphins if I tell
Adam GaSe three weeks ago today you're
gonna be the coach of the Jets three
weeks from now
what does Adam GaSe of three weeks ago
say if you would have told me the week
before that I probably would have said
you were crazy before the Buffalo game I
probably that wanted to shock me why do
you say that I don't know it's you can
always feel when something's not right
it's just one of those things when
you've done this long enough you you
realize kind of where you stand and
there was open dialogue so you know I
was hoping we play better I hope I was
hoping to win that game you know it just
would have been it would have been
better for us if we would have went in
the offseason 18:8 do you think it would
have made a difference in what unfolded
in Miami if you had won that last game
it could've you know we'll never know I
mean maybe it is you know will you win
that game and there's just always a
different feeling after a win how much
did you push things to a head in Miami I
mean I don't want to spend a whole lot
of time talking about it I'm just
curious because there was a sense that
the owner was gonna take his time and
and think things through did did you in
any way take the bull by the horns and
say look I may have other opportunities
I want to know what's going on I don't
want to twist here for a week or two I
want to know where I stand
no that wasn't that wasn't something
that I had to do or was looking to do I
I was focused on trying to help us win
that that last game and really keeping
our guys focused and not listening to
the outside noise you know it was
starting to get a little water at that
point and you know we were trying to get
the guys that we had available to us to
play as well as they could we knew we
were in for a challenge when you eat
struggled with Josh Allen the last time
we played them we knew we were going
into an environment where
fans we're gonna be fired up because
there's gonna be Kyle Williams his last
game so we knew we had a lot of things
that we had we had to overcome but after
that game ends is your mindset I'm gonna
sit back and wait and see what happens
or is it come on let me know where I
stand so I can make plans of my life I
knew we were gonna talk to next day so I
mean it was it was already I knew that
there was gonna be a conversation on
Monday why was it important for you to
get right back at it instead of taking a
year off like Mike McCarthy did yeah you
know what I thought about it and I
didn't have a ton of time to think about
it but I knew I was gonna do the
interviews but then I I knew I always
had the opportunity to sit back and say
if I don't want to do it then I can pull
away if I wanted to be a coordinator I
have opportunities there if I don't want
to do that I can go coach my son's
flight football team that was his
suggestion and I wasn't really feeling
that I really have to hear him complain
enough he's six he's got a lot of ideas
and I'm really a one way kind of guy I
want to do it the way I want to do it
he's got his own opinion how big of a
deal is it for you to stay in the
division you know the team's you know
the Dolphins you know the Jets from
having to face them how much of an
attraction was that it's a huge
attraction because you already know the
division you know the team you just came
from the hardest thing the thing that
I'm trying to to really get caught up on
is the actual offense of the team I'm
with because I spent more time going
against the defense I'm trying to learn
our offensive personnel here and the
rest of the rest of the division I for
the most part I know well enough
everything seemed to move so fast this
year in the hiring cycle the first week
was quiet but for the interviews but
then the dominoes started to fall very
very quickly how surprised were you that
those jobs started to fill up as quickly
as they did last week one on Monday two
on Tuesday three on Wednesday with I
don't think anybody had a second a
second round of interviews it was one
interview make your decision and go how
surprised were you by that
I think there's more than what you
realize just because you don't have to
fly back in I mean with FaceTime and
Skype and all that stuff that makes it
easier for front office guys and may
ownership you know players if they have
players involved to be able to FaceTime
you or Skype you and basically you can
you can answer questions face to face
without your problem without being there
and I think that interaction is is a
good part of that process because now
you don't have guys flying back and
forth hey I want to ask you this I want
to ask you this it's just more
personable when you do it that way did
you talk to Sam Donald before you got
the job offer in New York I would he was
involved in a three wave FaceTime which
that was the first time I learned that
there is a three-way FaceTime and I've
been just randomly doing it and I think
that you can do like even more than that
I haven't tried a bus in the commercial
they have eight Elvis's all
communicating with each other at the
same time from all across the world what
was your impression of D'Arnot after
talking to him in that setting before
you actually got the job offer I love
the questions he was asking he was he
was on it for what he was what it was
going through his mind what he was
looking for
the questions he was asking me about
offense kind of how I've gone about in
the past of handle in certain situations
just and just football wise and and with
quarterbacks in the offense I just you
could see there's there's there's a
great energy about him to where he loves
his game he's he's got that fire in him
where he's always looking to learn and
anytime you're around a young kid like
that that already kind of has that part
of it that's that's a that's something
you want to be a part of a lot of times
you have to you have to get young guys
to understand a athletic ability only
gets you so far as its expanding your
mind it's making sure that you're
constantly learning that's the key to
being a great player what's the benefit
of getting a kid early in his career
versus various other stages and you've
had Peyton Manning late in his career
you had Tim Tebow fair
the early Jay Cutler late in his career
what's the benefit of getting Sam Donald
right now with one year of NFL
experience I think this is the youngest
I've ever had and an experience with a
quarterback so every of the older guys
that I've had you know it's the back
half of their career physically there
were limitations there and they were
fighting through injury and just just
father time basically where now it's
like all right hey you're 21 your body
feels great you recover quickly you can
make all the throws you can move around
it's just it's an it's almost like a
it's a new experience for me I think
it's an exciting one I'm really I'm
anxious to kind of get going and I know
that you love to make sure everybody
knows when the the CBA rules really
start taking place so I know I can't do
anything till April so I mean I'm I got
a ways to go I just want I want to get
to that point I detect some sarcasm in
your response really I was kind of
laying it on pretty thick that's part of
the reality right you're limited in when
you can actually work with this guys Jon
Gruden was very loud about it last year
multiple times complaining about these
rules I mean how do you strike that
balance and I know you can't communicate
with them but but you want to get going
I mean how do you occupy yourself at a
time when you'd prefer to just be
working with your quarterback well in
the first year at least you you're
putting together staff you're evaluating
your own players which that's where and
I've heard this for I don't know how
many years and and I remember when I
first got to Miami I always heard you
know the biggest mistake people make is
they miss evaluate their own and really
that's where you have to do a great job
in that process when the coaching staff
gets here is evaluating your own guys
and making sure that that we know
everything and that we don't make a
mistake to where we let a guy go that's
really ends up being a good player for
somebody else we can't have that happen
we have to do a great job with our own
guys and then making sure that we hammer
down the free agency and we do a great
job there and then the draft and that
way then we finally get with our own
players
so I mean we got some time but we got
plenty of stuff that we can do in the
meantime we just have to make sure when
our players do get here in the spring
that we're ready to rule everything is
clean there's no grain our guys can just
roll you guys have a ton of cap space
how do you balance the search for
players when you're gonna have guys with
the dollar signs in their eyes that are
thinking about getting the most possible
money they can versus guys we're gonna
fit into the team structure that you're
gonna be trying to build I think a lot
of times when you when we get to that
point because it feels like an eternity
away I know it's not but it feels that
way I mean we're not even done with the
current season as it is but when we do
get to that point it's just it's one of
those things where relationships
throughout the league you know there's
so many guys that you've been around
that you know even on other teams that
you've you've met throughout the years
you know guys that you can call or
there's guys that you can other players
you can talk to her or that you've heard
talk about and that say hey this guy's
always been a great guy and you always
memory bank stuff like that when you
ever if you're ever worried about a
guy's character usually hear about it
before we even hit his free agency you
know I've sensed at times in the past
when you're dealing with the South
Florida media that that there's been and
I senses an overriding desire to protect
your players and not say anything that's
going to put them in a compromising
position and if there's any heat to be
taken you want to take it instead of
them but that's a very different media
environment a different media attitude
than what you're dealing with in New
York what's been your early impression
of the differences between the folks in
South Florida and the folks you're
dealing with now well I've only done I
mean I had that one day of three hours
or whatever we did I mean it was really
the same routine it's weird because you
never think three years later you're
going to be doing the same thing and
going through that process it is what it
is it's three hours of media I mean it's
a it's a grind and you're going through
it and you you're trying to keep
bringing that energy throughout the
three hours and you know you never want
to say anything that's you never want to
get ahead of yourself you want to make
sure you focus on what you're doing
which is for us it's the coaching like
coaching staff we're trying to put that
and it's everybody wants to get ahead of
what you're doing it's just it's hard to
give answers with that and I know it
sounds like you're being evasive in
things like that but you're not you're
just that's where you're at right now in
the process it's hard from it's always
hard for me to go with too far ahead
because that's just not how I operate
this on how I think your biggest are so
far greg williams is defensive
coordinator what attracted you to him
yeah I think it's just I mean I've known
him for it's I don't even know ten
twelve years you know he's he's somebody
that I've gone against multiple times I
always enjoyed facing him because I knew
what kind of team I was going to be
going against I knew there was always
some it's just there was an energy that
was brought any time that we played a
game where he was a defensive
coordinator because I knew what he was
bringing he knew what my offense was
gonna bring as far as intensity and
physicality and just the the grind that
we were gonna put into that game and I
I've always wanted to work with him I've
always wanted to go against him in
practice I felt like I loved the way
that his players feel about him the
Swagger the attitude that he brings to
his group I loved his experience and the
fact that he's been a head coach and
he's coming off I mean he goes to he
takes over a Cleveland deal and then
there wouldn't bowl games over there and
and he's acting like this is what it was
this was what it was gonna be the whole
time like he didn't even blink an eye
like he wasn't surprised and I love that
about him I love the way that he his
attitude is just infectious and I think
one of the dynamics when you get into a
professional football organization or
really any football team you get a
collection of alpha males and you have
to figure out how everybody's going to
get along and you've got a strong desire
to win strong personality type a Greg
Williams strong desire to win strong
personality type a how do you get to the
level of comfort that everything is
gonna work out and everybody's going to
get along and there aren't gonna be any
issues I don't we're here to win that's
what we're here to do I'm not I don't go
into this thinking hey this is gonna I'm
worried about
I'm worried about this I'm not worried
about anything I'm worried about how are
we gonna win football games how are we
gonna get our guys ready how are we
gonna put the best team possible how are
we gonna put the best coaching staff
together and that that's why Gregg is
the the first guy that really that we're
getting on board right now is he's gonna
be involved in with with doing that and
I when he gets here than him and myself
we're gonna hammer this defensive staff
I'll get that put together and then
eventually the offensive staff is going
to come together and then then we're
going to be ready to roll like I'm
excited I I just keep picturing practice
of this is what's going to be the
difference maker for us is it's gonna be
like a game every day because the
competition and the competitiveness
between Gregg myself
the staffs that's what you want that's
how you get that energy you want to
where the players feel that they're
practicing like that they're creating
that attitude so now all of a sudden
becomes the fourth quarter it's a close
game our guys have been there before the
New York Post has already brought up the
bounty issue I know it's been seven
years but Gregg Williams was right in
the middle of that it was a black eye
for the Saints for the league does that
come up at all in your thought process
is there even a little piece of you that
has to resolve that everything's fine
there it's not going to be an issue it's
not gonna be a problem it's not gonna be
something that drags us down we can get
past that I just Gregg Gregg paid his a
great great was penalized for that
heavily and football was taken away from
him like Heep he did his time and you
know that's what makes this country
great right it some people get second
chances all the time he's gotten a
second chance he's done it right he's
gone and he has worked extremely hard to
do things right and for me to media or
anyone else to hold that over his head
to me is it's wrong it's it's just like
when we give players second
opportunities it's the same thing people
make mistakes we've moved on from it he
paid it he did his time and to me I'm
that's something I'm not even concerned
about before we wrap up I want to go
back to what your life must have been
like that week after the Buffalo game
Monday it ends in Miami and instantly or
you are with
into this interview cycle for all of the
vacancies give me an idea what goes on
when you go in for an interview what
kind of preparation goes into it what do
you put together what do you even have
time to put together when you're fired
one day and you're interviewing with the
Cardinals the next day yeah you think
quick on your feet you know there was a
lot of the good thing was I had an idea
of the moving pieces that were going on
in the coaching world with who could be
available coaching staff wise teams were
great with me and we're willing to talk
through understanding that hey I was a
head coach on Sunday I'm fired on Monday
Tuesday I'm on a I think it was
Wednesday I was on a plane to interview
at Arizona
I stayed there came back flew out Friday
to go see the Jets flew back or I
actually went from Arizona to New York
and I went New York to Florida and then
interviewed with Green Bay on Sunday so
I mean it was everything was fast I was
doing the best I could of putting the
staff together listening to who had
doesn't like ohoo what guys were stands
where I could just have a staff kind of
ready to present to ownership before we
wrap what would you say to Jets fans out
there who were just skeptical they'd say
well it really didn't go well the last
two years in Miami and the time in
Denver that's all Peyton Manning that's
not gas and we don't really know what to
think about this guy what would you say
to those fans who were just kind of
taking a wait-and-see approach I just
look at it like this we're gonna put in
the work we're gonna be able to when we
get to Sunday that's really going to be
our test and that's if people need to
wait to Sunday and see wins and losses
and they need to go through a that's
like I get it but I guess I'm the kind
of person that is I'm gonna put we're
gonna put the work in we're gonna be
ready to go we're looking to win so
that's that's kind of our mindset that's
what we're looking to do we have
expectations as a coaching staff we have
expectations as players and we're going
to look to meet those expectations April
when the schedule comes out who do you
want week one Patriots or the Dolphins
ooh I I'm not gonna Mike you can't you
can decide that you
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna do all right
I think I know I think I know I'm a guy
take the Dolphins every week for 17
weeks including the bye week
oh that's just I want Obama I'm all for
bye week I've gone through one of those
16 straight weeks of stuff that's true
that's right that was one of the things
that hung over that season in 2017
people say what went wrong what went
wrong is everything went wrong for the
Dolphins that year I mean it's not an
excuse it's a reality so hopefully
you'll have your starting quarterback
for a full season hopefully you won't
have games moved around and by weeks
taken away and hopefully you'll have
fewer of the adversities that you had to
deal with the last two years in Miami
coach appreciate some of your time all
the best going forward look forward to
talking to you down the road I
appreciate it Mike
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports